we now have an update on a story that  you brought us here on monday we  introduced you to tanisha jones she is  struggling to make her rent every month  and get this one eight news now viewer  was so touched with her story they  stepped up to help the single mother  just know two months represent got paid  today  it means that god is good and i trust  and i'm just so grateful i'm happy it  means sleep  it means peace  it needs hope  it just means  hope  it means hope  we love bringing you these stories by  the way our viewer wished to remain  anonymous but thank you jones tells us  the donation was accompanied by some  yellow roses and she was told that that  color means guess what  hope